il a parallèlement la guitare 10
monsieur le premier ministre
en principe qu est ce qu un budget c'est
une vision stratégique de long terme
avec en ligne de mire
l'équité fiscale et une baisse
nécessaire des dépenses qu'est ce qu'un
budget façon socialiste tout le
contraire c'est d'abord un président de
la république qui fait des promesses à
tout-va notamment des baisses d'impôts
d'un montant de deux milliards d'euros
et qui vous demande ensuite monsieur le
premier ministre de faire les fonds de
tiroir pour honorer ces annonces
au moment de son annonce cette baisse
d'impôt n'était pas financé et ne l'est
visiblement toujours pas en effet
quelques jours plus tard le ministre des
finances fortes et les rames et
déclarait je cite on est capable de
trouver 2 milliards de d'économies
supplémentaires je sais que c'est
possible
voilà qui est rassurant à côté de cela
votre plan d'économies est encore très
flou et vous continuer d'augmenter les
emplois aidés ou de fonctionnaires
prenons par exemple le financement de
l'audiovisuel public quelques jours
avant la présentation du budget le
gouvernement se décide enfin la
redevance n'augmentera pas au delà d'un
euro mais dans le même temps vous
augmenter la taxe sur les fournisseurs
d'accès à internet d'un tiers ce qu'ils
ne manqueront pas de répercuter sur les
factures des français après les taxes
différé voilà donc une nouvelle taxe
déguisée
encore une idée lumineuse incapable de
trouver des économies vous reporter de
trois mois ces allégements sur les
entreprises
histoire d'où faire gagner un peu
d'argent quitte à rogner encore une fois
vos engagements
bref le gouvernement panique et les
français les entreprises trinquent
ce budget bouclé comme on improvise une
recette de cuisine laisse une forte
impression d'amateurisme art par votre
événement sûr la baisse très concentré
des impôts nous restons sur notre faim
monsieur le premier ministre pourrions
nous connaître si elles existent votre
stratégie budgétaire à court et à long
terme
je vous remercie m
la parole est à monsieur le secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget merci madame la
présidente monsieur le député monsieur
le député tardy est ce que j'ai l'air de
paniquer
oui ce gouvernement a une stratégie
monsieur le député la stratégie elle est
claire et elle a été annoncée il ya
quelques années
la stratégie consiste à mettre en place
50 milliards d'économies sur trois ans
et c'est ce que nous faisons
vous pouvez toujours chercher les
contours qui serait floue regardez je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure le passé
éclaire l'avenir nous l'avons fait en
2014 selon fin en 2015 et nous le
referons 2016
alors concernant les recettes les
recettes nouvelles
j'ai entendu le président de la
commission des finances nous alarmer au
mois de juin a joué à se faire peur a
dit il va manquer trois milliards de tva
3 milliards d'impôts sur le revenu non
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
gouvernement ne panique pas pour la
première fois cette année les recettes
fiscales sont au rendez vous on nous dit
que le déficit de la sécurité sociale
explose la ministre de la santé marisol
touraine vous le démontre jour après
jour ce gouvernement réduit les déficits
de la sécurité sociale s'en déroule sans
des remboursements sans diminution des
prestations et en finançant ses
priorités et ce sont bien ses priorités
qui concerne la justice l'éducation
nationale et l'insécurité qui sont mises
en oeuvre dans ce budget alors vous
pouvez du tout regretté que ça n'aille
pas suffisamment vite mais en tout cas
ça se fait avec un cap et avec une très
grande sérénité
merci la parole